On July 10th, 2014, police officers in Coffee County Georgia entered a private yard
where six children were playing.
The officers, who were in pursuit of a criminal suspect, ordered the kids to get facedown on the ground.
When the family dog came out into the yard one of the officers fired at the dog twice but missed.
One of those bullets struck a ten-year-old in the back of his knee.
When the child's mother attempted to sue the officer for damages the case was dismissed
due to qualified immunity, a legal doctrine that effectively shields police from most civilian lawsuits.
Following the police killing of George Floyd and growing calls for police accountability,
this once obscure doctrine has been thrust into the national spotlight.
Qualified immunity. Qualified immunity. Qualified immunity.
More people are starting to look around and take notice at what's gone wrong with policing today,
and are asking gee, is it the fact that the police officers are officially above the law?
Maybe that's part of the problem.
William Baude is a professor at the University of Chicago,
and the author of a widely cited paper arguing that qualified immunity should be overturned.
Qualified immunity is a judge-made doctrine that says that when you sue a government official
for violating the Constitution you can't get anything.
You can't get any recovery or any damages, even if they did something unconstitutional.
Unless they also did something that was clearly unconstitutional or if the court has put this as
you can only recover damages against an officer who was plainly incompetent or who knowingly violated the law.
Incompetence or that an officer acted illegally on purpose is difficult to prove in court,
and there were many examples of individuals clearly harmed by police error but unable to collect damages
because specific issues of a case hadn't yet been clearly established as unconstitutional in a previous case.
One case is thrown out because of the difference between unleashing a police dog
to bite a motionless suspect in a bushy ravine and unleashing a police dog to bite a compliant suspect
in a canal in the woods.
If you or I or any normal person is accused of violating the law and we say,
oh I didn't realize it was illegal, or, I knew this was a gray area but I thought I could kind of skate by.
That's not an excuse. There's an old adage ignorance of the law is no excuse.
And the one group of people for who it is an excuse are the government officials who enforce the law,
who you'd think should be held more accountable, who if anything, are actually trained in the law
and should know what they aren't supposed to do.
This sweeping protection was never voted on or signed into law but was instead created over decades
of judicial actions to give government officials room to make judgment calls without fear of lawsuits.
In 1871 Congress passes the Civil Rights statute that we still have today the Ku Klux Klan Act.
That statute doesn't say anything about immunity it says that when a government official, a state official
violates their constitutional rights you can sue them for damages.
A hundred years later in 1967 Chief
Justice Earl Warren decides the statute
doesn't quite mean what it says and that
there was a kind of unwritten defense
that sort of preempts the statute and
provides these kinds of defenses.
In 1982 in a case called Harlow versus
Fitzgerald they announced the modern
qualified immunity test which says you
can only sue a police officer if they
violate clearly established law.
Then in the forty years since then there's been a drip of maybe 30 or 40 cases where the court makes the test
a little bit harder every time and makes it really hard to find  anything to be really established law.
So because this is a judge-made doctrine the court can fix that anytime they can they could step in and say,
oh actually we you know made a mistake and the doctrine shouldn't be here,
or we've gone a little bit too far and we need to make more clear that isn't supposed to be impossible to recover.
But Congress can also fix it so because it's just an interpretation of a statute that Congress wrote.
Congress also has the
power to step in at any time and try to
either change the doctrine or repeal it
entirely weeks after the killing of
George Floyd revitalized the criminal
justice reform movement the Supreme
Court dealt a blow to reformers by
declining to here a set of cases
questioning the constitutionality of
qualified immunity
meaning that currently the only hope for
quick reform is legislation like the
bill co-sponsored by libertarian
congressman Justin Amash I've been
concerned for sure are they concerned
about our drug laws and qualified
immunity is just another example of a
justice system that is not working for
people
the current qualified immunity bill
proposed by representative Amash would
basically eliminate the doctrine entire
and it's a little bit awkward to think
about how do you pass a bill to get rid
of a judge-made doctrine because the
doctor is already not in the bill so
what do you do pass an empty page that
just doesn't contain the doctrine that
already wasn't there that doesn't work
so the bill just adds a paragraph to the
civil rights statutes saying it shall
not be a defense that the police officer
was acting in good faith it shall not be
a defense the police officer did not
know his conduct was lawful shall not be
a defense that the conduct though
unconstitutional was not clearly
unconstitutional it just sort of names
what the doctrine of qualified immunity
is and says no most congressional
support is coming from Democrats I don't
think there's any reason for it to be a
partisan issue I think you know if
there's anything we still all agree on
it's things like the rule of law and
government officials obey the
Constitution as long as that have
hopeful that people will will come
around to that basic idea the White
House recently called broad qualified
immunity reform a non-starter a stance
Attorney General William bar has
defended I don't think you need to
reduce immunity to go after bad cops
because that would resolve certainly in
police pulling back it's no policing is
the toughest job in the country what we
ought to do but the fact that government
officials have to make hard decisions is
think carefully about what legal rules
what constitutional rules we want to
restrain them and then try to figure out
how to train them and make them obey
those rules rather than make a bunch of
rules and then decide we don't care when
the rules are violated
I don't think reforming or even
abolishing qualified immunity is gonna
change all the problems we have with
policing in this country you know
there's a lot of research that police
unions are another huge part of the
problem because they make it really hard
to hold bad apples accountable even if
we all know who the bad apples are and
then of course there's a serious
argument that it's not just about bad
apples that there's much bigger
structural problem with the way we
license the use of violence against our
own citizens so qualified immunity is
not going to fix all of that it will
make it easier to correct individual
constitutional abuses to make sure
courts are are actually part of the
conversation rather than just sort of
ignoring the whole thing and I do hope I
could be wrong with this but I do hope
that by creating the sense that that the
police are not above the law that it
could sort of lead to some of the bigger
cultural changes we probably need
you